Father in Heaven this morning again we
thank you that you've given us a chance
to
rejuvenate a little bit over the break
and we pray now Lord the Holy Spirit
would again Inspire us and Lord
Enlighten our minds keep us alert and
awake so that we can understand what you
would have us to understand about the
gift of Prophecy this morning the
authority of the Prophet we ask it in
Jesus name amen
we're talking about prophetic Authority
now if you look at the handout there I
picked up this story from
a newsletter some time ago and I just
thought it goes so well with the idea of
authority this is an actual uh broadcast
or a conversation that was picked up it
says here the following is National
radio conversation of a U.S naval ship
with Canadian authorities off the coast
of Newfoundland October 1995. radio
conversation released by the chief of
Naval operations on 10 10 95 and here's
how it went the Canadians talked to an
oncoming ship
a U.S naval ship as you see well you
know United States and Canadians hey you
guys you know we're the U.S Navy please
divert your course 15 degrees to the
South to avoid a collision the American
response recommend you divert your
course 15 degrees to the north to avoid
a collision
now they think they're talking to
another boat hey look we're not moving
you guys move
Canadians negative you will have to
divert your course 15 degrees to the
South to avoid a collision Americans
This is the captain of a U.S Navy ship I
say again divert your course
Canadians know I say again divert your
course
this is the aircraft carrier USS Lincoln
the second largest ship in the United
States Atlantic Fleet we are accompanied
with three destroyers three Cruisers and
numerous support vessels I demand that
you change of course 15 degrees to the
north I say again that's one five
degrees north or counter measures will
be undertaken to ensure the safety of
the ship Canadian response this is a
lighthouse your call
I thought that was pretty good
but what it conveys to me is the
stubbornness
of you of the human will sometimes to
submit to Authority
so often we want the other to divert
their course
but I want to tell you something this
morning God's not diverting his course
he's the lighthouse and if you and I
want to be saved we've got to divert our
course amen and so we're talking about
the authority of the prophet
um under the section section two there
we've this is kind of we we touched on
this the other day the gift of Prophecy
has always guided God's Church in safe
paths this gift
in accordance with Ephesians chapter 4
has a equipped the church for Ministry B
edified the body by giving clear
Direction and reproof when needed in the
areas of evangelism health education
foreign missions publishing Etc letter C
it has brought doc unity and doctrinal
understandings and teachings letter D it
has preserved the body from the many
deceptive doctrines that have been
introduced and E it's challenged God's
people to strive toward Christ's
likeness of character until we come to
the measure of the stature of the
fullness of Christ
that's what the gift of Prophecy those
are things that the gift of Prophecy was
given for number three how has this been
accomplished one word authority
God has invested His prophets with
authority authority is what makes a
prophet effective
a prophet without Authority is like a
justice system without Law Enforcement
Officers or a lion without teeth or
claws
if a prophet has no Authority everything
he says is Simply Good Advice do you get
the idea there there are a lot of people
today questioning the authority of the
Prophet does Ellen White have the same
Authority as the Bible does Ellen White
have how much Authority does the prophet
have we talked about the degrees of
inspiration it's all about Authority
why would somebody care if what what
degrees of inspiration what's the big
deal who cares why would somebody ask a
question like that is Ellen White as
much a prophet is Ellen White as
inspired
you know why people ask questions like
that because she says something they
don't want to practice
if you're living in a court you know
Ellen White said that my writings she
says the spirit of Prophecy would have
never been needed if God's people would
have studied the Bible you've read this
probably yeah
with the intent in and I'm paraphrasing
of putting his teachings into practice
God has given
um authority to all of his prophets and
the purpose for you know again if you
and I think about this for a minute the
people that argue some people just argue
and I
I've encountered this on more than one
occasion where people will argue about
the spirit of Prophecy well why do we
have this and why do we have that now
let me ask you a question
if the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy
or in accordance with with each other
and if you're really practicing the
Bible in your life is the spirit of
Prophecy going to bother you
no
the only time it's going to bother you
is when your life is not in accordance
with the Bible unless the spirit of
Prophecy isn't in accordance with the
Bible
and that's where the issue comes in
people say well and we believe in
Seventh-Day Adventists that it is in
accordance with the Bible and for that
reason
should there be a problem with the
authority should we be asking well I
don't think Ellen White has as much
Authority as the Bible does who cares I
mean who would make that distinction in
other words the point is if if we
believe in the Bible we believe in the
spirit of Prophecy why would we try to
lessen the authority of it
if Ellen White does not have the same
Authority as Bible prophets what's the
purpose of having a last day prophet
well here's somebody with good advice
right God's given a last day Prophet
here's what she wrote take it or leave
it yeah that's pretty interesting but
I'll choose to do it this way because
she doesn't have the same Authority as
the Bible Prophet what use is that
we got people like that Billy Graham Max
Lucado we've got people like that we've
got to have it Dwight Nelson we've got
people who write books and we can pick
these little books up and we can read
them and
what purpose is there to have a profit
if the prophet does not have authority
so that when they say something that
holds the authority the same Authority
as the Bible prophets held
this is what we're going to talk we're
going to look at in some text in the
scripture this morning
we're going to look at how the Bible
displays or refers to the authority of
the prophets I want you to start out
with me in Luke Chapter 20. Luke chapter
20.
Matthew Mark Luke
Luke chapter 20
and we're going to start in verse 1.
Luke chapter 20 verse 1.
this is one of those other times the one
of those times we were talking about
earlier where Jesus is questioned
and he doesn't seem to answer exactly
what they asked him
Luke 20 verse 1. now it happened as one
of I'm sorry it happened one on one of
those days as he Jesus
taught the people in the temple and
preached the gospel that the chief
priests and the scribes together with
the elders confronted him and spoke to
him saying tell us by what what
by what Authority are you doing these
things or who is he who gave you this
Authority why are they asking that
question
why
they don't like what he's teaching see
if you have authority where do you get
the authority where do you get off
teaching what you do where do you who
gave you the right
see because if you don't have the right
you don't need to be here see they're
just wanting to get him out of the way
that's what that's any time anytime you
question authority that's the whole
purpose why you know why why did Lucifer
rebel against Authority in the beginning
didn't want to follow it okay so they
come to him and they're saying hey who
gave you the right to do this who gave
you this Authority verse 3 but he
answered and said to them
I will I also will ask you one thing and
you answer me the baptism of John
was it from heaven or from Men
and they reasoned among themselves
saying if we say from Heaven he's going
to say why didn't you believe in him
but if we say from men all the people
will what
Stone us for they are persuaded that
John was a what hmm
so they answered that they did not know
where it was from
and Jesus said to them then neither will
I tell you by what Authority I do these
things
now why didn't Jesus answer their
question why did he answer it the way
that he did but he really he didn't
answer the question but why did he put
the the question to them the way that he
did what was what was going on there
speak up
did you hear what he said
Jesus knew listen to me Jesus knew that
if they weren't going to accept the
authority of John the Baptist they
wouldn't accept his authority because
both they both came from the what
same place
where did John the Baptist get his
authority
from heaven
right where did Jesus get his authority
from the father
so
Jesus knew when they came and tried to
trap him with a question again
that if they wouldn't acknowledge John's
Authority he could talk all day long
about where he got his authority from
but they wouldn't acknowledge it either
you follow that
now we're going to see what we're going
to see is this thing consistently
repeated in different places in the
scripture but it's amazing they were
questioning the authority of Christ and
they also notice what it says they
didn't believe in John
you notice that if they had believed in
John they would say well we believe it's
from heaven and Jesus could have said
well you know where I got my authority
now
are you with me
okay
underneath there you see that the uh
it says does Jesus answer them only with
a question you tell me where did John
the Baptist give us Authority they
refused to answer his questions so Jesus
answered there's why we we I just
touched on that number two those who
rejected John the Baptist rejected
Christ I want you to see that in Luke
chapter 7.
Luke chapter 7 this is paralleled in
Matthew 11. both of them have similar
experiences but Luke 7 shares a little
peace that is not in Matthew 11 that
we're going to see here
now in Luke chapter 7 we're going to
start here in verse what do I have down
there verse 24 okay
uh just to give you a little background
John the Baptist was in prison
and the people
began to
um
John as he was as he was in prison he
was discouraged he began to wonder if
Jesus is really the one that he had
foretold
he began to doubt whether Jesus was
truly the Messiah so he sent Disciples
of his and said go ask him some
questions for me I need to know I need
to find out and those disciples came and
asked Jesus and Jesus basically told
them the ministry he was doing
that that was exactly a fulfillment of
the Prophet the words of the prophet
Isaiah he said you go tell John the
things you've seen and heard
and Jesus knew John would pick up on
that but as Jesus finishes there he
turns to the multitudes and begins to
speak to them about John the Baptist
verse 24 when The Messengers of John had
departed he began to speak to the
multitudes concerning John
what did you go out into the Wilderness
to see
a reed shaken by the wind
but what did you go out to see a man
clothed in soft garments indeed those
who are gorgeously apparel
and live in luxury or in King's courts
but what did you go out to see a prophet
yes I say to you more than a Prophet
this is he of whom it is written behold
I send my messenger before your face who
will prepare your way before you for I
say to you among those born of women
there is not a greater Prophet than John
the Baptist but he who is least in the
kingdom of God is greater than he verse
29 notice what it says and when all the
people heard him even the tax collectors
what
Justified God how do you justify God
what does it mean to justify somebody
okay to set right or
to declare right to declare innocent in
essence you know if I tell if if if I'm
in an argument with you Steve if you I
mean let's say you and Kevin are in an
argument there Stephen and and I say uh
you know what what what happened here
you know and and Kevin you say well
Stephen just did this to me you say Hey
Stephen says hey wait a minute the
reason I'm doing that is because he did
this and besides and I say Stephen
you're just trying to justify yourself
or Kevin you're just trying to justify
yourself what am I saying a sense
essentially
when I say you're trying to justify
yourself what am I saying
trying to declare yourself right you're
trying to declare your innocence and so
you don't usually see this word
justified in relation to God it's
usually in relation to man
so all this is saying is when the people
heard Jesus words about John the Baptist
even the tax collectors declare the
justice of God declared that God was
right
in other words they declared you know
what God was right in sending John the
Baptist we sure needed it
even the tax collectors Justified God
having been baptized with the baptism of
God I'm sorry with the baptism of John
it was the baptism of God at the hands
of John
but notice what it says in verse 30 but
the Pharisees and the lawyers rejected
the will of John for themselves not
having been baptized by him
thank you
is that what it said the will of John
who did they reject
they rejected the will of God they
rejected the counsel of God for
themselves having not been baptized by
him the Pharisees and the lawyers had
not received John's baptism therefore
when they heard Jesus talking that
didn't mean anything to them but the tax
collectors and those who had been
baptized by John those who had received
John's Ministry
we're prepared to receive Christ's
Ministry
that's why the Bible said John would be
a messenger to prepare the way
how did he prepare the way for Christ
he preached the gospel of repentance and
when people came to the point of
repentance they were ready to receive
the Savior but here's the point
those who rejected
John
also rejected Christ
and though they could have said well I
believe when God sends a true Messenger
the fact is if you won't hear the voice
of God through his prophet
neither will you hear the voice of God
anywhere else
do you follow that that's what we see
the principle there we're going to see
it again and again because I want you to
be clear on this uh no degrees of
inspiration we looked at that already
yesterday let's go to number three those
who reject the servants rejected the son
Luke 20. let's go to Luke 20 making it
easy we're staying in Luke here for a
little bit
Luke 20 verse 9.
Luke 20 and verse 9.
the Bible says then he began to tell the
people this Parable certain man planted
a Vineyard leased it to Vine dresses and
went into a far country for a long time
now at vintage time he sent a servant to
the vine dressers that they might give
him some of the fruit of the vineyard
but the vine dressers beat him and sent
him away empty-handed
again he sent another servant and they
beat him also and treated him shamefully
and sent him away empty-handed and again
he sent a third servant that is and they
wounded him also and cast him out then
the owner of the vineyard said what
shall I do I will send my beloved Son
probably they will respect him when they
see him
but when the vine dresser saw him they
reasoned among themselves saying this is
the air come let us kill him and The
Inheritance may be ours so they cast him
out of the vineyard and killed him
therefore what will the owner of the
vineyard do to them
he will come and destroy those Vine
dresses and give the vineyard to others
now what's he saying here
who are the servants that that were sent
first of all who's the vine dresser
God who are the servants
the servants were the prophets that God
sent
it was Harvest Time send the prophets
out but what they do to the prophets how
do God's people in in the past respond
to God's prophets
prophets that God's true prophets have
never been popular did you know that
they've never been some have had a
little more success than others
but they've never been popular so they
beat the servants they sent the servants
away you know what happened to the
prophet Isaiah right
King manasseha had him put in a hollow
log and saw it in too
that's what Paul's talking about in
Hebrews we talked about those who have
been Saun asunder
guys
that's not in the Bible by the way
that's a historical fact
Josephus I believe is the one who
recorded that but I'm not positive
but it's a historical piece of
information now the point is that God
sent the servants they rejected the
servants so then in the parable
obviously we know who the Beloved son is
but the point to follow the point to get
out of this is those who reject the
servants
also reject the Sun you're talking about
it's the same voice
it's the same voice of authority if you
reject the voice of authority in one
place you're going to reject it in
another place
it's not an issue of who it was
it's a it's an issue of the fact that
it's the same Authority you know we
often convince ourselves that well
somebody else
you know now we talked earlier and I
mentioned how we each have an ability to
reach people differently
but here we're talking about rejection
and as they rejected the prophets of God
um God couldn't reach them through other
means God couldn't reach him through his
son when they rejected his servants
those who reject the servants reject the
son look at number four with me
Matthew 10
verse 41.
and verse 41.
uh actually we should start with verse
40 there I skipped verse 40 and it
should say 40 there 40 to verse 42.
Matthew 10 verse 40 notice what Jesus
says he who receives me
receive I'm sorry he who receives you he
told his disciples has he sent them out
he who receives you receives what
me and he who receives me receives what
him who sent me
he who receives a prophet in the name of
a prophet shall receive her prophet's
reward and he receives a righteous man
in the name of a righteous man shall
receive a righteous man's reward and
whoever gives one of these little ones
only a cup of cold water in the name of
a disciple now surely I say to you he
shall by no means lose his reward the
principle there he who receives you
receives me who receives me receives him
who sent me
Jesus also came in the role of a prophet
you remember Jesus said of himself a
prophet is without honor in his own home
because he too is a spokesperson for God
he was the prophet of all prophets he's
the one Moses wrote about in Deuteronomy
18 said the Lord shall raise up a
prophet among you from among you like
unto your brethren him you shall hear he
was speaking of Christ
and Christ says he who receives me
receives him who sent me that goes for
any Prophet that goes for any messenger
of the Lord when you reject
let me put it this way
let's say you sent a very important
message to somebody a friend of yours or
some acquaintance and you you sent it by
the hand you couldn't go yourself and
maybe Jack I sent you and I said Jack
now I want to send you to uh Daniel I've
got an important message for Daniel and
I want you to go and tell him thus and
so
and so Jack goes to Daniel and Daniel
says I'm not going to believe it unless
it comes from him
how do I feel about that
I I've sent him a messenger I've put
confidence in a messenger and he's
rejected the messenger I just sent how
do I feel about that how would you feel
about that
okay
are you with me
when God sent the messengers when God
sent the prophets you know that's that's
God sent somebody in his behalf
brothers and sisters I want to tell you
something you and I don't understand
what's involved in sending a profit
you and I don't involve no what's
involved I mean if we could con if we
could if we could compute uh travel
expenses from Heaven to Earth just to
send that angel to give the prophet the
message
or whatever it would take
you know we can't we can't equate that
and of course we say well that's
ridiculous you don't have costs involved
in that they don't have any air Heaven
flights going from but listen
it is
think about this for a minute would you
sometimes we think about heaven we think
about
it doesn't even have to be Heaven
sometimes you know what sometimes when
it comes to ministering to people we
think you know what I don't want to go
out and give studies tonight I just like
to stay at home and kind of take it easy
I'm comfortable it's cold out
it's drizzly I just think I'm going to
stay home tonight you ever feel like
that
now what's more comfortable where you
are or where the angels are what's more
beautiful what's more pleasing
I should rephrase that
what's more comfortable where you are
are heaven in the paradise of Heaven
oh you know if you could be anywhere
you'd be in heaven right
where are the Angels
are they in heaven
are they saying you know what I'm just
it's so much more comfortable up here
than that dark cold planet Earth
is that what they're doing
no we're the angels
yeah they're here this morning
you know we've got it good we've got
good Angels here we've got evil angels
here this morning the good angels are
trying to make you get trying to convey
to us truths and help us to pay
attention the evil angels want you to
doze off
you think I'm joking
they've given up all just to
Aid Humanity
in being saved
for God to send a messenger to his
people is a big thing for a person for
God's people to reject that messenger is
to reject God
he who he says he who receives me
receives him who sent me could we
likewise say he who rejects me rejects
him who sent me we certainly could we've
even seen the principle already
when God sends a spokesperson
remember it's just a spokesperson when
you reject the spokesperson you reject
the one who sent that spokesperson
what kind of authority then does that
spokesperson have
all authority
amen
let's go to the next one there
uh the next text there Ezekiel three
four through seven let's look at that
one real quickly
Ezekiel 3 4-7
Ezekiel 3 verse 4. notice what it says
here
then the Lord said to me
Ezekiel says son of man go to the house
of Israel and speak with what
my words to them for you are not sent
this is this is tough for you are not
sent to a people of unfamiliar speech
and of hard language but to the house of
Israel
not to many people of unfamiliar speech
and of a hard language whose words you
cannot understand surely had I sent you
to them they would have listened to you
but the house of Israel will not listen
to you because what
because they will not listen to me
I'll tell you what brothers and sisters
when you listen
the heart is what
deceitful above what all things I want
to tell you something when the word of
the Prophet comes to you and challenges
you and you say well I just don't agree
with that
be very very careful
and ask yourself if it just may be that
the reason you don't agree with it is
because it cuts right across the course
of your sin
ask yourself am I just rejecting the
messenger or am I rejecting the one who
sent the messenger
what an incredible that's a that's one
that's one of the saddest passages in
the Bible
if I'd sent you to people that had a
difficult language that spoke a
different language from you and could
hardly understand what you said they
would have received your message he says
but because you went to the house of
Israel that's why they won't receive you
because they won't listen to me
for all the house of Israel are impudent
and hard-hearted
pray the Lord that it would not be so
Among Us here today
he who receives you receives me let's
look at the next one now this one I
really like this one here John 9 28.
you've heard people say well I don't go
by the spirit of Prophecy I just give me
the Bible the Bible in the Bible only is
what I go by I don't need no Ellen White
have you heard that have you heard that
by Adventists
I've heard that by seventh Adventists
well they say they're Seventh-day
Adventist maybe I would call them
non-practicing
some of the Adventists
Ron Duprey I don't know if you know who
ran Dupre is did he teach here this year
okay uh he he may tell you the story
about he's his sister he says currently
a non-practicing Seventh-Day Adventist
and uh he'll probably talk about that if
not you can ask but it's there's no such
thing as you're not an Adventist if
you're not practicing Seventh-day
Adventist I mean
uh I'm a non-practicing Christian
you know
anyway
John 9 John 9 and verse 28.
now listen this is just incredible once
again
as the leaders come to Christ and
they're wanting to argue with him
uh in verse 28 it says then they reviled
him and said
you are his disciple
but we are what
Moses disciples
we know that God spoke to Moses as for
this fellow we don't know where he's
from
question was Jesus in the Bible
at that time was Jesus in the scriptures
at the time that this was spoken that
this was written yeah
let me rephrase that now Jesus doesn't
have a book in the Bible of course the
Bible spoke about Jesus what I'm asking
is
Jesus says in his role as a prophet was
he was he canonized
no was Moses
yes in other words they had the Bible
they said we got the Bible but we don't
know who this guy is well all he needs
Moses
we got Moses we'll listen to him but
we're not going to listen to you buddy
because we've got the Bible and that's
all we need you follow that that's
exactly what they were saying
they had Moses they don't need him we
got Moses and said listen we know we
know that God spoke to Moses as for this
fellow we don't know where he's from we
know God spoke Through the Bible but as
for Ellen White we have no idea where
she's from we're not going to listen to
her we're going to listen to the Bible
you follow that
look at John 5 verse 44. look at what
Jesus says
along those same lines John 5 verse 44.
John 5 and verse 44.
it says
Jesus speaking here how can you believe
who receive honor from one another and
do not seek the honor that comes from uh
from the only God
do not think that I shall accuse you to
the father
there is one who accuses you Moses in
whom you trust
for if you really I'll add believe Moses
you would believe me for he wrote about
me
and if you really
believe in the Bible and the Bible only
you'll believe in Ellen White
because the Bible wrote about Ellen
White and we're going to see that in our
next session
but if you do not believe his writings
Jesus says how will you believe my words
repeatedly we see the idea that if you
reject Authority in one place you're
going to reject it in the other if you
reject God's Authority I should say in
one place you're going to reject it in
another
do you follow that
notice what it says there below
uh in in letter
uh A1A that quote at the bottom of the
page you are not familiar Ellen White
says you are not familiar with the
scriptures
if you had made God's word your study
with a desire to reach the Bible
standard and attain to Christian
Perfection that's an important Clause
that sometimes people leave out
you would not have needed the
testimonies not only does she say if you
made God's word your study but if you've
made in essence God's word your study
with an intent to put it into practice
in your life
you wouldn't have needed the testimonies
it is because you have neglected to
acquaint yourself with God's inspired
book that he has sought to reach you by
simple direct testimonies calling your
attention to the words of inspiration
which you had neglected to obey and
urging you to Fashion your lives in
accordance with its pure and elevated
teachings
Ellen White has not written something
new
it's pointing it back to pointing us
back to the Bible that we claim to
follow and oftentimes really don't
you follow that
look at the next one Acts chapter 13 and
verse 27. Acts chapter 13 and verse 27.
acts 13 and verse 27.
the Bible says
for those who dwell in Jerusalem and
their rulers
because they did not know him speaking
of Jesus
nor even the voices of the what
prophets which are read every Sabbath
have fulfilled them the prophets in
condemning him
because they did not know him neither
did they know the prophets the voice of
the prophets because they rejected he
all that it's saying here is because the
people rejected Paul saying that because
they rejected uh Christ that proves that
they never followed the prophets
if they would have followed the prophets
they would have received Christ but they
they rejected both in essence
it's impossible that somebody could have
accepted the profits and rejected Christ
impossible
you follow that
no I don't care how much they would have
said we believe in Moses like we've just
seen and there's no way
and in the same way I'll tell you I will
maintain this for you as Seventh-Day
Adventists there's no way if you really
believe in the Bible that you're going
to have an issue with Ellen White you've
got issues with Ellen White you've got
issues with the Bible you've got some
spiritual issues in your life
you follow that
you have a question all right next uh
the also first Thessalonians 2 15 we see
a similar thing right there first
Thessalonians chapter 2 and verse 15.
we'll start in verse 14.
the Apostle says for you Brethren became
imitators of the churches of God which
are in Judea in Christ Jesus
for you also suffered the same things
from your own countrymen just as they
did from the judeans who killed both the
Lord Jesus and their own Prophets
and the only point I'm making there is
again that I believe the scripture is
making there is that correlation that
those who reject Jesus reject the
prophets you're not going to accept one
or the other they they
killed both the Lord Jesus and their own
prophets of course they claim to believe
in the prophets but it was their fathers
who killed them
and though they claim to believe him in
crucifying Christ they were crucified
the prophets afresh Etc back in both the
uh vice versa
because it was Christ who spoke through
the prophets testifying what or what
manner of time the spirit of Christ who
was in them did prophesy right
anyway
let's go to this
uh some of the statements there below
or the statement that I have right there
there below that
note here that those who reject the
message of the prophets ended up
fulfilling the warnings of those
prophets by crucifying Jesus isn't that
interesting
they claim to accept the prophets and
they did exactly what the prophet said
that the they would do
the very things the prophets said that
the enemies of Christ would do they've
you know have you ever thought about
that you'd figure you know when they're
you figure when Judas is about to sell
Jesus for 30 pieces of silver he would
have thought about the prophecy in
Zechariah and said wait a minute
this might not be a good idea right I
mean all of the prophecies that they
went through to fulfill and anyway
or when they or or when that when the
Pharisees had gotten there were that
when the priest had gotten that money he
threw it on the he can't Judas comes
back and tosses it on the temple floor
in a fulfillment of the Zechariah
prophecy you know and they're sitting
there and say what should we do with
this well let's buy a Potter uh Potter's
field Temple 30 pieces cast into the
house of God
to the Potter maybe this is a bad idea
fellas but
you know it's just an Evidence again
that they did not really receive the
words of the prophets let's go to Luke
16 27.
let's go to Luke 16 27.
Matthew Mark Luke 16
and verse 27.
Luke 16 and verse 27.
now this is the parable of rich man and
Lazarus the rich man in Lazarus notice
the the end of this these words are
powerful that are spoken here and this
kind of goes along with what we were
saying earlier about getting that one
right text boy I could just get that one
then he said I beg you therefore verse
27. I beg you therefore father father
Abraham that you would send him to my
father's house for I have five brothers
that he may testify to them lest they
also come to this place of Torment
Abraham said to him they have Moses in
the prophets
let them hear them
and he said no Father Abraham but if one
goes to them from the dead they'll
repent
but he said to them if they do not hear
Moses and the prophets
neither will they be persuaded though
one rose from the dead
that's a powerful stat text right there
they don't believe Moses and the
prophets they're not going to believe
if you don't want truth you don't want
truth
if you're going to reject the truth here
you're going to reject it anywhere look
at some of the statements down down
below that one
when a view of scripture is presented
many do not ask is it true in harmony
with God's word but by whom is it
advocated
and unless it comes through the very
channel that pleases them they do not
accept it
you know Ellen White says that uh
contending or or arguing over the uh oh
I'm I'm butchering this statement it's
in the uh it's also in the study Bible
under First Corinthians chapter
3 where they talking about I am of Paul
I'm of Apollos I am of kephus and they
argue this thing over
um
Ellen White says that's that's uh
let me see your study Bible brother I
don't I really don't want to butcher
this for you
if I remember enough of it sometimes
I'll
I'll attempt it but I I want to get this
thing right
listen to this there can be this is from
uh it's in the study Bible on First
Corinthians 3 4 through 9.
also in alamites comments on the SDA
Bible commentary uh from the
I don't I the reference here says
Redemption the teachings of Paul Pages
74 and 75 I'd like a better reference
but this is what she says there can be
no stronger evidence in churches that
the truths of the Bible have not
Sanctified the receivers then their
attachment to some favorite minister
and their unwillingness to accept and be
profited by the labors of some other
teacher who is sent to them in the
Providence of God
oh well this isn't the ah
it's like people in my church well I
thought Pastor however was going to
speak today
or I thought Pastor Ashford was going to
speak today you know well and you know
we're expecting this and we want this
teacher we want that teacher she says
that's the strongest evidence we've not
been Sanctified by the truth of the word
you've got to listen to truth you've got
to listen for truth wherever it comes
you know God sends a messenger today
listen listen up
you have worship here every morning
listen
God speaks through the people who to
carry out worship God spoke to this
brother this morning I hope you were
listening
um
God God doesn't play favorites God will
use anybody as a messenger so perk your
is up and this is what she says too many
people they they if it doesn't come
through the channel that pleases them
they don't accept it
rather than saying well is it truth
so thoroughly satisfied are they with
their own ideas that they will not
examine the scripture evidence with a
desire to learn but refuse to be
interested merely because of their
prejudices and listen to this next part
the Lord often Works where we least
expect him
he surprises Us by revealing his power
through instruments of his own choice
while he passes by the men to whom we
have looked as those through whom the
light should come
foreign
well if it's really truth Mark Finley
will preach it
you know
God desires us to receive the truth upon
its own merits because it is truth
if they won't hear Moses in the prophets
doesn't Lord says Jesus himself in this
little apparel if they don't believe it
they're not going to believe it no
matter who I sinned
because they're rejecting truth
do you follow that
let's look at Luke 23 verse 8.
Luke 23 verse 8 this is a fascinating
passage as well all of these things are
just basically hammering down that same
point in different places of the
scripture
Luke 23
8 and 9.
verse 8
it says here now this is during the
trial of Christ and Christ was sent from
pilate to Herod
and it says in verse 8 now when Herod
saw Jesus he was exceedingly glad for he
had desired for a long time to see him
because he had heard many things about
him and he hoped to see some miracle
done by him
then he questioned him with many words
but he answered him
nothing
now do you ever read that and say well
you know it says pilate or it says Herod
wanted to see him why didn't Jesus say
something maybe he could have turned him
around have you ever thought about that
why did he answer him nothing
he already sent John
Jesus had said everything that needed to
be said to Herod through John the
Baptist
and he rejected John the Baptist and had
his head cut off
there's nothing more Jesus could have
said to him
see we expect God to speak to us through
the channel we want
God sends whom he will and you and I
need to ask ourselves is it God's truth
if we don't we're in a dangerous
position look at what this next
statement says the the number three down
there those are misnumbered by the way
but uh from testimonies three page 63
says whoever turns from the light in
what
one instance hardens his heart to
disregard the light upon what
other matters you know what she says
this in context too
does anybody know let's finish reading
it
whoever violates moral obligations in
the matter of eating and dressing
prepares the way to violate the claims
of God in regard to Eternal interests
well he said diet's not that important
it's not about diet it's about Authority
have you submitted to the will of God if
God has a will for you in diet
or in dress
or in how you give Bible studies it's
all the will of God and the authority of
God you're not in a safe place to reject
his authority in any place
are you submitting to him or not that's
the question
whose authority are you following she
says when you return from light in one
instance whoever turns his light from in
whoever turns from the light in one
instance hardens his heart to disregard
the light upon other matters
because it's light you're rejecting
light it's never safe to reject light
look at this next part here uh the next
quote I've got two the number two I've
got number two three and two there so I
apologize had Elder Smith and those
United with him been standing in the
light
they would have recognized the voice of
warning and reproof
but he calls it a human work and casts
it aside
the work he is doing he will wish undone
air long or before long
he is weaving a net around himself that
he cannot easily break
and sister white says this is not my
opinion Elder Smith had been urging that
this was Sister White's opinion so she
just wants to State very clearly pardon
me this is not my opinion here this is
counsel from the Lord and look at what
she goes on to say what voice will you
acknowledge as the voice of God
what power has the Lord in reserve to
correct your errors and show you your
course as it is
in other words the Lord sends a prophet
what else does he have you know we say
well the Lord send something else he
send everything he said everything that
he can say through this messenger what
else is he going to say she says what
voice are you going to acknowledge the
voice of God what has the Lord in
reserved to correct your errors
you have by your own course closed every
Avenue whereby the Lord would reach you
will he raise one from the dead to speak
to you if you refuse to believe until
every shadow of uncertainty and every
possibility of Doubt is removed you will
never believe
the doubt that remains the doubt that
demands perfect knowledge will never
yield to Faith
what faith do you need when you know
everything
Faith Comes faith is trusting what you
don't know
the word of the Lord comes to us all who
have not resisted his Spirit by
determining not to hear and obey
how do we resist his spirit
by determining not to hear and obey
this voice is heard in warnings in
councils in reproof it is the Lord's
message of light to his people if we
wait for louder calls or better
opportunities the light may be withdrawn
and we left in darkness that's a very
heavy statement isn't it
all it's saying is when God speaks
through the prophet
listen
don't say well it's not quite as
authoritative here or there is it the
voice of God is it truth then listen
carefully
the last text I want you to look at
a very sad text in second chronicles 36
you know God has spoken God has spoken
through the Prophet Jeremiah with
testimony after testimony he had labored
with the people over and over
and they continued to reject his
ministry
until we come to Second Chronicles 36
verse 14. Jeremiah said listen
to what the Lord has to say and you
won't go captive into Babylon listen to
what the Lord has to say now listen
um
God sent a message to King zedekiah and
told King zedekiah that you know Babylon
was going to come Babylon was going to
rule over them but they could have ruled
over them in Jerusalem
if they would have submitted to
Nebuchadnezzar they could have still
remained in their City much like the
Jews remained in Rome
they didn't have to have the Babylonians
come in and kill and pillage and
everything else in that destruction
of Jerusalem
they may have been servants but it could
have gone a lot easier and Jeremiah
warned and warned and warned but the
people didn't listen
and finally second chronicles 36 verse
14 tells us this
moreover all the leaders of the priests
of the people and I'm sorry all the
leaders of the priests and the people
transgressed more and more according to
all the Abominations of the Nations and
defiled the house of the Lord which he
had consecrated in Jerusalem and the
Lord God of their father sent warnings
to them by his Messengers rising up
early and sending them because he had
compassion on his people and on his
Dwelling Place
why did God send The Messengers
because he what
he had compassion on his people
just you read you you read some of the
Lord's councils to you and it doesn't
feel compassionate sometimes
but it's because he has compassion all
God's counsel is so that we can be saved
in his kingdom he sent the messengers
because he had compassion on his people
verse 16 but they mocked The Messengers
of God they despised his words they
scoffed At His prophets until the Wrath
of the Lord was a rose against his
people Till There Was what
no remedy what does that mean
what's that
no solution nothing else to do nothing
left to do God did everything he could
to preserve his people even when they
needed punishment he wanted to make the
punishment as mild as possible
but they kept rejecting they kept
rebelling to the point where God finally
had to allow them to be taken captive
many destroyed
there was no remedy
you know it's interesting to me
the Bible prophecy foretells a last day
spiritual Babylon
literal Israel
were taken captive to literal Babylon
because they rejected the counsel of the
prophet
God says in the Book of Revelation that
Babylon has soon to become a cage
for every uh unclean and hateful bird a
hold for every foul Spirit a hole the
cage there are those who will be trapped
in Babylon that can't come out
and is it possible
is it possible that spiritual Israel may
be in danger of being trapped in Babylon
because they reject the voice of God's
last day prophet
I think that's more than probable
God has spoken to us
with authority
and we need to regard that Authority as
one that God has given because he has
compassion on his people
listen carefully he'd carefully those
words that God has spoken through his
prophet and not just his Prophet as we
talked about today God will send
different Messengers to your past he may
send a friend to you
what nerve you have what right do you
have telling me about whatever don't do
that
when somebody comes to you and wants to
point out something that may need
correction in your life listen
and let me tell you something else
I've had people who've come and pointed
out things that I've done wrong that had
no concern for my welfare
that have had no interest in in fact you
know just very critical they didn't care
how I felt in fact they were trying to
you know they'd like to see me destroyed
if possible but listen to me
I still have to ask myself
is what they've said true
because it's just like the devil isn't
it to try to try to take somebody who's
got an ax to grind with you
to come and talk to you with an attitude
so you'll say I'm not going to listen to
what they had to say
the devil knows what our faults are if
he can tell one of his servants to come
up and bring it up to us then that'll
make you and I say I'm not going to
listen to that
if somebody says something to you in
regard to your own character always ask
yourself the question is it true
if it is take it to the Lord and put it
away
it cleansed and go forward
and you'll be a better person for it
amen